hi i'm chris bench chief curator at the
strong National Museum of play in
Rochester New York and this is every top
toy for the last 50 years so how did we
come up with this list of 50 it's based
on twice that had biggest cultural
impact the toys that changed the face of
play and the toys that all of us
remember most 1969 Snoopy astronaut it's
the year that first person walked on the
moon was something that so many
Americans remember where they were
iconic event in popular culture and who
else really got into the astronaut
business everybody's favorite comic
strip beagle Snoopy Snoopy astronaut it
was perfect for the American mood of the
time 1970 the Nerf ball the Nerf ball
was credited to ren Geyer a freelance
toy designer
the nerf Bob wasn't gonna be a plaything
it was going to be a game originally it
was going to be a Flintstones war of
foam rocks game by one of the creators
of twister well the folks at Milton
Bradley hated the idea they passed on it
Parker Brothers took up the concept and
they tossed out the game but they kept
the phone they thought it could be the
first indoor ball that kids could toss
around without making mom and dad irate
that they were gonna break something
the Nerf ball sold four million copies
in its first year of really blistering
pace nerf is huge right down to the
present this is how we play 1971 wiebel
don't fall down a proper rule makes
weeble toys weebles wobble but they
won't fall down the advertising tagline
that made these little egg-shaped
playing pieces characters so popular
that year from romper room they have a
counterweight in the bottom so you can
pop them around and they will not fall
over they're perfectly sized for
toddlers hands they are ideal for
playsets like this Wild West version and
they came in so many variants
ever since and have been popular toys
for kids across the decades 1972 you
know it all started with the Robbins
family in Cincinnati Ohio Merle Robbins
was barber his extended family loved
playing the card game Crazy Eights but
family members kept forgetting the rules
of the game so he marked the
instructions right on the cards
eventually his family concluded that
wouldn't it be great to have a
customized set that included the rules
odd the cards the result was the game
uno it became a grassroots craze and by
the time that 1972 came around uno was a
hit
1973 skateboards skateboards have been
around years before especially homemade
versions they were credited to surfers
who used them as an alternative for days
when there wasn't any food served
although they had a surge of popularity
in the 1960s
it wasn't until 1973 that skateboards
really took off thanks to two big
technological developments one was what
were called Cadillac wheels they were
composite wheels that were smoother
faster rolling that any wheels that had
come before and there was new
specialized axles or trucks as they were
called that were made especially for
skateboards with both of those features
skateboards could become more
controllable suitable for tricks
skateboards didn't receive TV
advertising and what really sold
skateboards was people seeing folks use
them demonstrations competitions and
watching the kinds of tricks watching
the agility that they allowed you
skateboards are part of our competitive
culture right down to the present with
iconic figures like Tony Hawk 1974
Dungeons & Dragons Gary Gygax and Dave
Arneson created Dungeons & Dragons they
were big fans of war games and other
simulation games and they took it in a
new fantastic dimension inspired by
things
like the Lord of the Rings book series
Dungeons & Dragons not only change
tabletop gaming and Lord new adults into
the world of games it gave you a
framework it gave her characters it gave
you a mode of play with those polyhedral
dice and it allowed you to spin
imaginative yarns with friends with
family and to really take yourself to
places that you've never gone before
certainly not with a traditional board
game it also influenced computer games
because those multi-sided dice and the
way that those controlled play were
perfect for the kinds of randomization
for all kinds of imaginative and
role-playing and strategy games in
online and on discs 1975 one of the most
brilliant fad toys ever if you want to
talk about making a million off of
something that's essentially worthless
this is what Gary Dahl did with the pet
rock he was a marketing genius in taking
rocks and packaging them in what were
essentially miniature pet carriers a
million were sold in the first year the
tongue-in-cheek manual that came with a
pet rock gave you instructions for how
to housebreak it you could set it on
newspaper and tell it to stay pet rocks
were also wonderful at learning how to
play dead and the manual gave you the
necessary steps to do it it was
hilarious
1976 The Bionic Woman and Cher why am i
showing two dimensions of American
womanhood for 1976
it's because there's such a great
matchup the Bionic Woman was a TV
spin-off of the series the Six Million
Dollar Man in which Jaime Sommers was
essentially a female superhero and if
you love the Bionic Woman you could get
the action figure essentially
indistinguishable from a dog with
beautiful clothes and styler bull hare
he was sort of an interesting midpoint
between Donna Reed Housewives of the
1950's
and someone who was kick-ass like Linda
Hamilton and the Terminator movies at
that same time Sonny and Cher were big
in variety shows at that moment share
with her Bob Mackie gowns was the
essence of elegance
they represent steps forward in feminism
and the Bionic Woman she was the heroine
of her own TV series 1977 Star Wars
action figures the toy that
revolutionized not only the toy industry
but the world of entertainment Kenner
took a contract to make toys for a
little science fiction movie that no one
thought was going to do any business and
they were so wrong they were glad to be
wrong but they were in trouble because
this summer movie release that became
the blockbuster to bust them off really
cried out for action figures what was
Kenner to do they did the cleverest
marketing technique of selling gift
certificates so many kids that holiday
season found rap gift certificates for
their Star Wars action figures because
Kenner couldn't get the figures made
fast enough these little action figures
and all the collateral vehicles and
accessories proved that movies could
make more money by licensing their toy
products than they could actually
selling tickets at the box office
1978 Simon Simon was a breakthrough idea
from Ralph Baer creator of the video
game concept Ralph was out to create a
really simple to learn toy he was
constrained by what microchips were
available on the market and he was
limited to cheap microchips sort of the
last previous generation that were
affordable for use and toys and all I
could handle were four different notes
Simon has set up intersection of
tabletop gaming and electronic play and
it's something that we're doing right up
to the present 1979 the Atari 2600
wasn't the first
home videogame system that was the
Magnavox Odyssey it may not have even
been the best in lots of people's
opinions but it was the Atari 2600 that
broke through into so many American's
homes and taught them that playing games
on your TV was a thing a thing that
people hadn't really considered useful
the Atari 2600 had a price point that
was appealing to people it also was the
game system that allowed them to play
the games they'd become familiar with at
arcades games like pac-man and space
invaders tired of spending all those
quarters now you could play it at home
1980 rubik's cubes fastest-selling
puzzle ever it was a creation of a
hungarian architecture and design
professor named Erno Rubik he was
trapped behind the iron curtain in
Hungary in a communist environment where
he came up with this great idea but he
really couldn't make money off of it
wasn't until his idea was brought to the
west by ideal toy company to the US
rebranded from being the magic cube to
rubik's cube and suddenly everybody had
to have one
at one point three of the top ten
paperback bestsellers on the New York
Times list were all about how to solve
the Rubik's Cube because everyone wanted
to know the secret and if you couldn't
figure out the secret people sold you
sets of stickers you could paste over
those grand bold sides and make it look
like you had figured out your Rubik's
Cube 1981 he-man and Masters of the
Universe
Mattel was looking for a way to
duplicate the success of Star Wars
action figures with little plastic
characters and they essentially took a
concept of their own the Big Jim action
figure and bumped him up and made he-man
into an absolutely absurd physical shape
and they a come
t-man and the rest of his Masters of the
Universe with an entire backstory that
they provided in comic book form so that
you knew all the characters you knew
that he man and Skeletor up against each
other in eternal combat he-man was by no
means the first property to make that
sort of leap between different forms of
media those kinds of things have been
going on since the 1890s but he was
really one of the ones that crystallized
it for our own era in the last 50 years
1982 Care Bears and My Little Pony so
what was so special about Care Bears
Care Bears were all about emotions they
were about kindness they were about
loving characteristics they were
cultivating the best kinds of behavior
and emotions it was something that
parents liked to train their children in
and they made them appealing and
heartwarming in a way that other toys
weren't I think what makes Care Bear so
appealing is their sweet nature YK Man
My Little Pony was a transmedia sort of
property that took a series originally
of six pastel horse figures with their
anthropomorphised faces and their long
silky Mane's and Tails and turned them
into a media juggernaut with TV series
with movies with ancillary products and
really produce expanding an equine
universe with horses that were sort of
crossed with dolls the Barbie variations
that sell best are ones that have the
most hair so Rapunzel Barbie is one of
the best-selling ones ever if you love
horses what could be better than a horse
that has a styler baleen and tail that
you can comb wash and have fun with in
that kind of stylist designer way my
little pony has gone through numerous
resurgence 'as perhaps least predictable
in 1982 is that there would be guys
known as
bronies who are fans of My Little Pony
in the present that is something that no
one could have ever foreseen 1983
Cabbage Patch Kids in the late 1970s
Xavier Roberts was creating art
sculptures essentially dolls that he
called the little people and you didn't
buy one of his little people you adopted
one with a unique face a unique name and
it was a really appealing concept but it
was something that got a groundswell
movement behind it he couldn't keep up
with the demand so eventually he
licensed the concept to a Coleco maker
of electronic toys that said that they
would be able to take his concept use
their manufacturing prowess to create
really customized dolls so that they
weren't all the same on the Shelf
different hair color eye color skin tone
each had its own name each still had
adoption papers renamed as the Cabbage
Patch Kids
they were the sensation of 1983 adopting
was a different concept for a doll it
gave you a different sort of investment
that you weren't just paying a price at
the checkout counter you were getting an
individual doll for you know nursery for
the Cabbage Patch Kids all under lock
and key of course the media loved the
idea of Cabbage Patch Kids and even more
once the craze took off and parents were
brawling in parking lots to get the last
examples of Cabbage Patch Kids at the
store that everyone wanted to have that
story and the more the story ran the
more people wanted Cabbage Patch Kids it
was something that really boosted the
sales of Cabbage Patch Kids to the
stratosphere 1984 Trivial Pursuit
board games had been on a decline trend
ever since the advent of television in
the 1950s but that all changed with the
1981 introduction of Trivial Pursuit a
trivia game that captivated grownups
in a way that games haven't previously
it's here Big Bird it's there it's
everywhere by 1984 the year were
recognizing there were parties
everywhere everyone wanted to play
everyone wanted to win Trivial Pursuit
was a hit 1985 Teddy Ruxpin he seems so
incredibly advanced at the time by
inserting a cassette in his back you
could make Teddy a character made
children's stories to your kids it made
him so engaging
it made him perfect night time
conclusion to a child's day even though
he cost a massive $69.99 in 1985 he was
the best-selling toy of the year Teddy
combined two things one was technology
of the time he seemed very up to date
for his moment but he also helped
promote literacy with reading something
that so many parents want to encourage
in their kids 1986 laser tag it was such
a great competition for all the sorts of
gunplay that have occurred over the
years this finally let you prove that
you had actually hit your opponent not
with a laser but with infrared beams so
that your opponent knew that they'd been
hit and that you had succeeded now
critics of the time felt that it was
encouraging violence and gunplay but
other folks said this was just a ongoing
way of competitive action that it was
more tagged than killing people it
generated so much success not only for
the laser tag product but by starting
laser tag emporiums and venues across
the nation that and their successors of
paintball and other kinds of grown up
and big kid play are popular right down
to today
1987 Jenga classic tower top wind game
dexterity to the empty
that anyone can play with enough
strategy and a steady enough hand to
actually maneuver the blocks out of the
tower and set them on top English woman
Leslie Scott had played a block toppling
towering game when she was growing up in
Africa when she went home as a grown up
to England she took this concept with
her it was a hit at parties it took us a
while for it to lift off but eventually
in Canada in the u.s. it became a
massive hit and eventually went back to
Europe as the sensation now Jenga is all
over the world in so many variations
1988 the Nintendo Entertainment System
1983 Nintendo introduced a Famicom a
system that was popular throughout Asia
that they rebranded as the Nintendo
Entertainment System or NES for the
North American market and in 1988 it was
the go-to system for people in the US
and Beyond because it had the best games
it had Donkey Kong Super Mario Brothers
The Legend of Zelda it became the
standard of its time and for many years
to come
1989 the Nintendo Gameboy all the power
and excitement of Nintendo right in the
palm of your hand if you loved the NES
in 1988 chances are that you wanted to
take your gaming portable and Nintendo
was out to do that with the Gameboy it
was a way that you could play your games
anywhere you wanted to go and rather
than having specialized games that only
allowed you to play football or baseball
the cartridges for the Gameboy allowed
you to have a multitude of game what's
needed a Game Boy it's a personal game
playing
system with over 200 puzzle action and
sports game to choose from it was simple
it was clear it was efficiently designed
it allowed to have head-to-head
competition and the Game Boy became the
standard gaming in terms of mobile play
the legacy of the Game Boy shows up in
all of our pockets and purses today as
we play games on our smartphones maybe
even play Tetris 1990 Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles in the 1980s Kevin Eastman
and Peter Laird work out to create a
satirical comic book that was making fun
of superheroes so they created a bunch
of mutant turtles who lived in sewers
were named after Renaissance artists and
thought that their tongue-in-cheek comic
book would be the end of it all what
they couldn't realize was that it would
go on to become its own media juggernaut
and lined of all sorts of toys that
became hit with kids who loved the
irreverent humor who loved the pizza
eating teenage characters that they
could relate to in a way that Batman
Superman spider-man really didn't
resonate 1991 the Super Soaker Lonnie
Johnson was working for NASA trying to
develop a water-cooled device for a
spacecraft and he developed a technique
that he was pressurizing water and
sprayed it all over his bathroom thought
you know this is not gonna work for my
project but it would make a great
plaything a Super Soaker took water play
to a whole new dimension kids and adults
loved it super soakers went from basic
versions like the one I'm holding to
once where the water capacity was so big
he wore it in a backpack 1992 Super NES
the successor to the Nintendo
Entertainment System brought new
capacity to gaming with a 16-bit system
that allowed more opportunities for
higher grade graphics faster play and
one of the things that's different in
video game systems than some other
playthings
that technology keeps advancing prices
keep coming down for computer chips
allowing greater and greater capability
so if you're a fan of a particular
series of games you want to have the
latest version the slickest gameplay and
that's what systems like the Super NES
allowed you to do 1993 Barney Barney
conveyed so many positive messages on
his PBS series a purple Tyrannosaurus
Rex was anything but the Jurassic Park
dinosaur he was unscary dinosaur who
represented really kindly qualities he
was perfect for toddlers and early
preschoolers he may have driven parents
crazy
but he was one that was a hit with the
kids and Barney became a cultural icon
in his purple dinosaur nests and his
friends across the PBS time frame 1994
Mighty Morphin Power Ranger
another transmedia property that became
a successful TV series which generated
successful toys which generated all
kinds of other licensed products along
the way the teen heroes of Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers with their color
coded gear were ones that were big hits
with American kids and they were so much
the flavor of the month that they were
the must-have toy for the holidays in
1994-1995
beanie babies this was marketing par
excellence to turn soft toys full of
little pellets into a collectible
juggernaut that dominated gifts stores
everywhere the beanie babies were
predicated on a perception of scarcity
that these were limited-edition toys
with their in-ear tags that made them
extra appealing allowed people to buy
them as investments they thought and to
create praises when they thought that
their favorite characters were about to
be retired and they better grab them now
1996 Tickle Me Elmo I was giving
everybody that giggling it's Tickle Me
Elmo there had been soft electronic toys
previously but Elmo was really more
advanced than someone like Teddy Ruxpin
his simulation of laughing and
uncontrollable joy from being tickled
was tremendously appealing and when he
was demonstrated on TV shows like the
Rosie O'Donnell show he helped create a
marketing craze and parents everywhere
competed to get their Tickle Me Elmo
he was the must-have toy of the holidays
for 1996 and he has persisted as the
most identifiable character from Sesame
Street right down to the present the
legacy of Tickle Me Elmo is that more
and more we expect even soft cuddly toys
to come with electronic component
or online linkage that means that it's
not just a physical thing it's something
that has greater capacity for play and
simulation than ever before 1997
tamagotchi if you weren't quite ready to
keep a cat or dog or even a hamster
Tamagotchi virtual pet might be just the
solution for you you could have a
keychain size tech to look after to care
for and to identify with it was a
digital virtual pet something
miniaturized in a way that hadn't been
seen or popularized before if you didn't
do it right
skull icon showed up at the bottom of
your screen that you were doing it wrong
and you could perhaps pull the fat out
of the fire and make sure that your
Tamagotchi didn't expire but it was a
lesson both in marketing digital play
and it was a lesson in pet care giving
that loads of people found popular for
years to come
1998 Furby Tiger electronics set out to
create a media craze for their
interactive talking jabbering cat Furby
and they did a brilliant job of it from
its introduction on The Today Show more
than six weeks before they were ever
available in stores the media picked up
on this interactive learning capable toy
in fact it was such a phenomenon for its
learning capacity that the National
Security Administration in Washington
banned Furbies from his offices lest
they pick up on state spy secrets and
share them with nefarious forces 1999
Pokemon car
[Music]
if you love the video games your shirt
loves the trading card game that it's
spun off that let you collect your
Pokemon compete with your friends in the
three-dimensional world pokemon cards
were so successful that they generated
tournaments where people could watch
competitions and compete themselves it
is an entire industry and an
entertainment force in its own right mm
the razor scooter scooters have been
around certainly since the early part of
the 20th century but the razor scooter
was slicker looking it was more compact
was foldable so you could carry it with
you when you didn't want to ride the
razor scooter allowed with its smooth
rolling composite wheels for you to have
a great ride and it became one of them
must have toys of the holidays the razor
scooter proves that even in an era of
digital play there's still a great
amount of Appeal for speeding along in
the real world on a wheeled vehicle 2001
Bratz dolls Barbie had dominated the
fashion doll segments for decades before
the advent of brats who offered an
entirely new look they had big heads
twig-like
limbs oversized kind of anime eyes and
what also made them different was they
were really multi-ethnic with names skin
tones hair colors that represented more
of the American population than ever
before they had an appeal to a tween
market who considered Barbies for babies
and they really took fashion doll sense
to a different level and really gave
Barbie a run for her money people have
said the Bratz are representative of the
sluta fication of American dolls I'm a
little more generous on Bratz I think
they really hope give options for doll
play 2002 they
we blades are essentially a rebrand of
an earlier toy from ideal battling tops
that had been a success in the 60s or
70s they promoted all kinds of
tournament play they were supported by
an animated cartoon series that allowed
you to see what was even more possible
it's sort of cool to think that
something that's been around for
centuries if not thousands of years tops
that are a persistent plaything can be
updated and made appealing to a
contemporary audience and people who
want to play in a digital age 2003
Robosapien if Furby is a little too
benign for you and you don't want a
story from Teddy Ruxpin why not this
massive robotic plaything that was a big
hit of the year he had learning capacity
he could dance he could fight he was
something that really made you feel
up-to-date by having this super-sized
and super capacity robotic toy 2004
puppy surprise when you get one of these
you aren't buying a puppy you're buying
a mother dog who comes with unborn
puppies inside and a Velcro slit across
her belly that allows you to reveal the
surprise number of puppies creepy or not
I'll let you be the judge
2005 webcams
like Cabbage Patch Kids webkinz inspired
you to not just get a pet but to adopt
it and webkinz came with internet
connectivity this is part of a whole
vanguard of playthings that weren't just
a three-dimensional toy but they had an
online component and a unique code that
let you go on there and play with your
friends interact with environments add
to your virtual pet as well as your
physical one going up against different
ecosystems like Club Penguin also of the
time webkinz were one of the most
successful and they were a huge deal for
kids everywhere in 2005 2006 the
Nintendo leads Nintendo's fifth
generation of consoles came with what
was called the Wii mote that was
gyroscopically controlled handheld
controller that let you use it as you
would a baseball bat or a tennis racket
or as your bowling ball that you were
sending down the lane it was so
intuitive especially for adults who
might not be familiar with other more
complex controllers it made a huge
inroad into the senior citizen market as
well as the kid-friendly market and it
really changed how people reacted to
games that they could do it in a very
natural way rather than just pressing
buttons 2007 iPod Touch this Apple
device wasn't just a music player it was
a platform for gaming as well with its
touch screen
it allowed really intuitive play it let
parents have confidence that they didn't
have to buy a smartphone for their kids
to play games or listen to music and it
was the latest iteration and a successor
to something like the Game Boy and with
the kinds of capacity for touchscreen
control that we assume is everywhere
today 2008 the littlest petshop
people have always loved miniatures and
tiny things whether that's dollhouse
furniture or charms on a bracelet and
little playthings have that special
appeal
the littlest petshop with its huge cast
of toy pets was an immediate sensation
it was built on a 1990s toy with a
similar concept and it has proven to be
a successful franchise with great
capacity for collectability and also for
playsets like this immense one 2009 Zhu
Zhu Pets meet mr. squiggles your
electronic toy hamster one of the
downfalls of hamsters and gerbils is
that they tend to be nocturnal animals
so they're asleep when kids are awake
and vice versa Zhu Zhu Pets have none of
that problem they also don't need to be
cleaned up after and their electronic
capabilities from they're cuddling
version two they're exploring version
they've got those two modes allowed them
to be a hit of 2009 with all kinds of
accessories so that you could have your
entire crew of animatronic hamsters
rolling around in balls and exploring
their habit rails 2010 Monster High
dolls inspired by the success of the
Twilight series of books and films
Mattel introduced a whole sequence of
high school students who were monsters
I'm holding Frankie Stein and there were
multitudes of other of her friends and
dates out there in the series they are
definitely the unbar be from Mattel with
their goth look they were ostensibly to
prove that everyone needed to fit in and
people could be varied looks and feels
although critics pointed out that they
were still stick thin and wearing short
skirts and lots of eyeliner a little bit
like they're competing Bratz 2011
Skylanders one of the most successful
iterations of the category known as toys
to life where three-dimensional
playthings interact online via a portal
that sends them into an online world
Skylanders generated lots of different
stories and characters and it was really
proof that people wanted to play with
three dimensions and online multiplayer
games 2012 the Nintendo Wii U building
on the success of the Wii the Wii U had
much more advanced graphics capacity and
it also had a new touch screen
controller that allowed you to play
games in multiple dimensions and to see
them on that screen as well it was a
carry on advance from the Wii and one
that was a success in its own right and
took things into greater processing
speed and speed of gameplay 2013 techno
the robotic puppy if you want more
capacity than a Furby techno allows you
to have a dog that can sing and dance
can sleep can do tricks he also makes
rude noises whether you like him to or
not and he is just the latest in a
series of advanced robotic playthings
2014 rainbow blue after techno the
robotic puppy it's good to know that
there's still an appeal to crafting
playthings and jewelry for your friends
using something as analog as a loom that
weaves rubber bands together and rather
than being a corporate product the
rainbow loom was a creation of an
individual entrepreneur and toy inventor
and Detroit who initially made these in
his home he washed the rubber bands in
his bathtub with an oar to get the dust
off of them and what he really tapped
into was the lure of social play of
creating gifts for your friends and
family for turning something
three-dimensional into something with
added value that kind of art kit that
kind of crashed project had an enormous
amount of Appeal stores couldn't keep
rainbow looms on the shelf they sold so
rapidly and it won four different
category
the toy of the Year awards 2015 the bb-8
robotic toy the breakout droid in that
year Star Wars movie the force awakens
was undoubtedly bb-8 the adorable
snowman shaped droid and everybody
wanted one for home this version for
spiro was amazingly advanced used
gyroscopic controls to move bb-8 around
your home through various tricks the
best part of bb-8 is he looks so much
like the one in the movies he's not just
like action figure of r2d2 he looks and
functions the way the droid in the
movies does it was what everybody wanted
and it was a perfect match for the
continuing demand of Star Wars fans even
40 years after the initial movie that
they still can't get enough Star Wars
and especially the robotic characters
2016 Hatcher moles the start of what is
now called the blind box kind of toy
where you don't know what you're getting
inside Hatcher moles were so alluring
because you bought an egg you didn't
know what stuffed toy was living inside
of that we had to warm them up with your
hands so that they would hatch and peck
their way out it was a thrill of
unboxing as umpteen videos have shown on
YouTube ever since and Hatcher moles was
the must-have holiday toy of 2016 and
continues in different iterations to
show that surprises and eggs are so
alluring to kids and grownups everywhere
2017 lol surprise carrying on from the
success of the hatch moles lol surprise
took that same concept not knowing what
was inside the package and turned it
into its own separate product this one
is lol surprise under wraps they're kind
of like mummies and you don't know
what's gonna be lurking inside of this
they have a reasonable price point so
that they're smaller than
camels and you could get lots of them in
your quest to get all the surprises that
are out there 2018 fingerlings
fingerlings cling to your fingers that's
where they get their name and they're
the perfect culmination of all the
trends that we've been seeing through so
many of these toys connectability
learning capacity microchips that enable
them to have so many tricks as well as
still having a 3-dimensional item that
you can cuddle and care for fingerlings
really in some ways are no surprise
they're really a way of pulling so many
threads that we've been seeing develop
across the history of toys and really
represent the way the miniature
technology and our expectations of
digital reality come together in a
three-dimensional plaything that sets
the stage for what's going to come next
we don't yet know what's going to be the
hot toy for 2019 but based on what we've
been seeing you can be pretty confident
that it's gonna have some cuteness
factor it may have some prized qualities
interactivity and online connect ability
all mashed together in a way that is
compelling for kids and grown-ups today
that's every top toy from the last 50
years I hope you learned something along
the way
and I can't wait to see what the next 50
years hold